- Xenia Fedorova, bonjour.
- Bonjour
Nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une chaine YouTube
qui s'appelle Thinkerview, une chaîne internet qui diffuse en direct.
On vous reçoit dans le cadre de votre activité à Russia Today. Vous êtes rédactrice en chef de Russia Today.
Vous allez nous répondre en anglais, nos questions seront traduites directement
en russe pour une compréhension parfaite de notre question.
Et on comprend suffisamment l'anglais pour pouvoir recevoir vos réponses
et notre communauté se chargera de sous-titrer par la suite vos réponses en français.
Comment allez vous ?
Oui, merci ! Ça va, merci beaucoup de m'avoir invitée. Je souhaite parler anglais
parce que je voudrais être très claire dans mes réponses, donc merci.
Et je suis contente d'être ici !
Je vous en prie ! Comment ça se passe votre arrivée en France,
votre lancement de Russia Today depuis décembre ?
La presse vous a bien accueillis ?
Nous avons eu un accueil très... chaleureux si je puis dire !
Chaleureux, bien sûr, j'exagère en étant sarcastique...
Cela fait quelques mois que nous nous sommes établis ici,
et nous avons lancé la chaîne il y a un mois.
Cela fera un mois dans quelques jours.
Et l'accueil a été très étrange.
Nous avons été dénigrés, et nous sommes toujours dénigrés
par la majorité des médias dominants.
Et pas seulement par les médias, mais par le chef de l'Etat lui-même.
- Le président.
- Oui, votre président, Emmanuel Macron.
On va revenir un petit peu aux présentations d'usage.
Vous êtes née en 1980 dans le chaudron du Tatarstan...
- Kazan.
- Kazan. Et qu'est-ce que vous avez fait ? Vous avez fait des études de journalisme
vous avez fait des études de diplomate, vous avez fait des études à Berlin ? Racontez-nous un petit-peu tout ça.
Je suis née à Kazan pour la simple et bonne raison que mon père y travaillait
en tant que scientifique et ingénieur pour l'armée.
Il a parcouru l'Union Soviétique, donc la plupart de mes frères et sœurs
sont nés dans des endroits différents.
Moi, il s'est avéré que je suis née à Kazan, un très bel endroit mais...
Vous savez, c'est un endroit où je n'ai vécu que jusqu'à mes 4 ans.
Ensuite, nous avons déménagé à Moscou. J'ai donc fait mes études.
J'ai commencé par la politique internationale, mondiale
puis je me suis tournée vers le journalisme.
A vrai dire c'est aussi parce que ma mère était journaliste.
J'avais l'habitude de faire du journalisme, j'étais habituée à écrire depuis mes 15 ans.
Donc dans un sens ça venait en parallèle à ma vie.
Et puis au bout d'un moment, j'ai réalisé que le journalisme était
ce que je voulais faire dans la vie
J'ai continué dans cette direction.
Donc vous avez fait un petit séjour à Berlin où vous avez interviewé à 26 ans,
je crois, Condolezza Rice.
En effet. Je vivais déjà à Berlin pour mon travail chez RT.
J'y ai déménagé il y a tout juste deux ans et demi.
Et, je ne suis pas sûre d'avoir bien saisi la question.
J'ai réalisé plusieurs entretiens durant ma carrière,
certains d'entre eux de personnes haut placées
Mais je pense que le journalisme ne se résume pas aux interviews ; c'est bien plus.
Il s'agit de regarder plus loin et de questionner les sujets auxquels
on est confronté quotidiennement
Pourquoi aller directement sur Russia Today à 25 ans et ensuite devenir responsable de la politique internationale ?
Et pourquoi avoir ensuite accepté de venir en France ?
J'avais 24 ans à l'époque et au tournant de mes 25, j'avais déjà un travail chez RT.
J'étais fascinée par l'idée... Vous savez, à cet âge je pouvais déjà voir qu'il y avait beaucoup de fausses interprétations
de désinformations à propos de sujets internationaux importants. Et j'ai senti que c'était un problème.
- Lesquels ?
- Tout. Déjà, les bombardements en Yougoslavie.
Quand la majorité des médias dominants approuvent ce qui se passe, et que la couverture (médiatique) est unilatérale, il n'y a jamais d'autres points de vue.
La couverture médiatique sur la Russie, également.
Ça a été interprété de différentes façons.
Et en tant que Russe je l'ai ressenti comme une injustice car tellement
d'autres sujets ne sont pas couverts.
Globalement j'ai eu la sensation que nous rations quelque chose.
Alors quand j'ai appris que la Russie lançait la chaine RT, j'étais très intéressée.
Mais je n'ai pas pu y entrer tout de suite. Je ne pouvais pas intégrer l'équipe immédiatement.
J'ai essayé de contacter des gens, sans succès.
Et c'est par pur hasard que j'ai fini par tomber sur quelqu'un qui travaillait pour RT.
Donc je suis allée à un entretien, et j'ai décidé de rester car
j'étais très enthousiaste à l'idée de réaliser quelque chose de nouveau.
C'était une équipe super jeune. Ma rédactrice en chef
Margarita Simonyan a mon âge, elle avait donc 25 ans à l'époque.
Imaginez, construire une chaîne d'informations avec une jeune équipe de gens
plein d'idées, et non bridés, ne pas être censuré...
C'est quelque chose que j'ai voulu et je ne l'ai jamais regretté.
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire de la charte de Munich ?
Plus personne ne s'en préoccupe, vous savez...
Ce sont les valeurs du journalisme qui ne sont pas respectées.
Je ne sais pas pourquoi, mais la manière dont le journalisme est perçu aujourd'hui
est très différente de la charte de Munich et je vois ça tous les jours.
Et je vois beaucoup d'autocensure, particulièrement en France.
Ici en France, il y a des sujets que les journalistes ne veulent pas aborder.
- Lesquels ?
- Eh bien, toutes les interventions militaires à l'étranger. L'Irak, suivie par l'Afghanistan...
Parlons de la crise humanitaire au Yémen ou des conséquences de l'intervention en Libye.
Vous avez une phrase en tête de la Charte de Munich ?
Il y a le fait de manquer d'équilibre. Je n'ai pas la phrase exacte en tête
mais le mot que j'utiliserais, c'est l'équilibre. C'est ce qui manque.
Et chacun a une compréhension différente de ce qu'est l'équilibre.
Là, ça fait trois fois que vous vous faites jeter par les services de presse de l'Elysée.
La dernière fois, c'était avant-hier si mes souvenirs sont bons.
Votre journaliste s'est fait jeter sous prétexte qu'il n'était pas journaliste alors qu'il avait donné sa carte de presse.
Est-ce que la communauté journalistique européenne ou française ; est-ce qu'il y a une solidarité entre votre profession et la profession des journalistes en France ?
D'abord, je pense que ça fait plus que 3 fois. On l'a rendu public 3 fois,
mais il y a eu plus de cas où l'on n'a pas été autorisé à entrer...
Ça a débuté avec la campagne d'E. Macron, où l'on n'a pas pu accéder au QG de campagne d'En Marche.
Quand quand E. Macron a été élu, on a essayé d'obtenir des accréditations pour entrer à l'Elysée à différentes occasions et on a obtenu aucune réponse.
Donc on envoyait juste des gens en espérant que ça fonctionne.
Il y a eu une seule exception, ce fut lors de la visite en France du Président Trump.
Pour une raison ou une autre, nous avons eu l'autorisation d'y assister.
Soit c'était une simple erreur, soit il y avait un but derrière tout ça, nous l'ignorons.
Mais ce qui me choque vraiment c'est qu'aucune communauté journalistique,
aucune organisation en France, n'est en fait prête à se positionner pour défendre les droits de la presse.
Par exemple, ce qui est arrivé juste hier à notre reporter, Kevin Berg : il est arrivé sur place, il a montré sa carte de presse
la dame à l'entrée l'avait entre les mains, et elle a dit :
"Oh, parce que vous travaillez pour RT, vous n'êtes pas journaliste."
- C'est quoi, son nom ?
- Le reporter qui travaille pour RT ?
- Non, la personne de l'Elysée.
Je ne peux pas vous le dire parce que je ne sais pas.
Ils seront toujours très attentifs sur ce point.
Régulièrement nous ne sommes pas pris pour des journalistes, mais quand on enregistre ou demandons une réponse officielle, il n'y a plus personne.
Je crois que c'est parce qu'ils ne veulent pas nous donner d'opportunités d'agir légalement, parce qu'on le pourrait.
- Quel type ?
- Pourquoi pas une plainte pour discrimination ?
Vous savez, la désinformation... Il y a beaucoup de fake news qui sont répandues à l'encontre de RT.
Bien qu'on nous appelle la Fabrique des Fakenews, nous sommes victimes de Fake News provenant de la majorité des médias !
Chaque jour, notre directeur de la communication, Lorenzo Ricci, me donne le résumé de ce que les médias ont publié de nouveau à notre sujet
Combien d'euros vos journalistes touchent ? Et quel est votre salaire ?
C'est une grande rumeur qui dit que nous avons des salaires incroyables
et que nous rachetons les gens. Ce n'est pas vrai.
En fait, on est dans la moyenne du marché, et je dirais
que nous donnons un peu plus aux juniors.
- Combien ?
- Ca peut aller de 1000 à 2000 euro bruts pour ces juniors.
Et ça dépend vraiment de s'il s'agit d'un temps partiel ou complet.
- Combien vous gagnez ?
- Je ne peux pas vous le dire parce que je n'y suis pas autorisée.
- Est-ce que vous payez vos impôts en France ?
- Bien sûr.
- Les vôtres, vos impôts ?
- Oui, aussi, les miens, parce que je vis en France à l'heure actuelle.
Je vais devoir les payer pour la première fois en mai, je pense.
Je me prépare pour ce moment important.
Mais puisque j'ai vécu en Allemagne, je sais que les impôts sont très élevés
comparé à mon pays. Très élevés.
Et ils sont plus élevés encore en France, d'après ce que j'ai compris.
- Pas une petite fourchette à nous communiquer ?
- Vous voulez parler des salaires ?
Exact, pour le salaire, pour ton salaire, c'est entre quoi et quoi ?
Non. Je ne suis pas autorisée à en parler, d'après mon contrat de travail.
Mais je peux vous dire que ce n'est pas autant que ce que reçoivent
certains gérants de média ici en France.
Et le truc c'est que je suis un cas spécial puisque j'ai été à RT depuis le tout début en 2005
Donc j'ai en quelque sorte construit ma carrière depuis un poste junior
jusqu'à la position où je me trouve aujourd'hui.
Je peux vous dire que je suis satisfaite de mon salaire mais que je n'ai pas eu d'augmentation depuis mon départ de l'Allemagne pour la France
et la vie à Berlin est moins chère qu'à Paris, je dois l'admettre.
Mais quelque part, cette question n'a pas lieu d'être,
ce n'est pas aussi important que le but de mon travail présentement.
Si j'étais là pour l'argent, je travaillerais pour quelqu'un d'autre.
Ce n'est pas pour l'argent, c'est sûr.
Vous êtes ici uniquement pour le défi ?
Et bien, je suis ici pour essayer de faire quelque chose de qualité, qui vaille la peine.
Je suis ici parce que je crois que la diversité des opinions est quelque chose de très important.
Et pour avoir une vue d'ensemble des événements, vous devez avoir des points de vue différents et des perspectives différentes.
Je pense que c'est d'une certaine manière ce qui manque à la France de nos jours.
Est-ce que vous avez l'impression que les deux dernières fois, par exemple pour le Sommet de Rome ou le déplacement du Président Macron à Calais
d'avoir été évincés parce que ces sujets touchent à l'immigration et que Russia Today a tendance à traiter ce sujet-là de façon plus corrosive par rapport à d'autres médias ?
J'attends que la dame traduise...
Je serai d'accord avec vous sur une chose, sur le fait qu'il y a un certain point de vue qui est considéré comme acceptable dans les médias.
Et ce qu'on fait, c'est qu'on ne suit pas les mêmes règles.
Nous croyons que ce qui est important, c'est de couvrir les sujets
au fur et à mesure qu'ils se développent.
Et s'ils se développent, on ne devrait pas essayer de les passer sous silence
ou d'en diminuer l'importance
Certaines personnes nous accusent de ne couvrir que les sujets violents, comme les affrontements ou les manifestations,
mais en tant que journaliste, resteriez-vous à l'écart ou éviteriez vous d'évoquer un violent affrontement avec la police dans les rues ?
Ne seriez-vous pas là, dans l'action, avec votre caméra live en streaming, sur votre site web, sur les médias sociaux ou ailleurs ?
Bien sûr que tu devrais. Tu le ferais, et tu devrais être là.
Et j'ai été témoin de cas où l'autocensure dans les médias était incroyable, vraiment. Comme en Allemagne...
- Sur quel sujet ?
- Pour parler d'une affaire récente
A Cologne beaucoup de femmes ont été agressées sexuellement
lors du réveillon du Nouvel An.
Il a fallu presque une semaine pour que les médias locaux commencent à en parler. Et je pense que c'est quelque chose d'inacceptable.
Ce n'est pas une question d'exagération, c'est en fait une question de reportage.
Et ensuite réunir les bonnes personnes pour analyser et expliquer ce qui constitue
le nœud du problème.
Mais quand les médias prennent la décision de ne pas couvrir un sujet ou un autre, ça s'appelle de la censure.
Et c'est comme si les médias prenaient le rôle de juge, pour dire ce que l'audience est autorisée à savoir ou non.
Ils tentent de manipuler leur audience en atténuant les tenants et aboutissants de cette info. Et je trouve que ce n'est pas bien.
Est-ce que vous pensez que vous faites peur aux journalistes mainstream français ?
Je pense qu'on les rend anxieux, non pas à cause de qui nous sommes ; mais parce qu’ils ont perdu la confiance de leur audience bien avant notre arrivée sur le marché.
Et ça veut dire qu'ils ne faisaient pas très bien leur travail.
L'inquiétude vient de la question: "et si RT faisait le boulot mieux que nous ?". Et ça je pense que ça leur fait peur.
Et c'est pas le fait que vous, vous soyez une femme brillante, avec un cursus international, avec 20 millions d'euros derrière et l'Etat Russe qui vous back ?
Bon, je distinguerais les deux sujets.
J'ai conscience de susciter de l'intérêt en tant que personne, personnalité et femme qui réussit
à travers mon cursus et une carrière notable,
mais c'est aussi le type d'intérêt qui est un peu cliché.
Le fait que je sois russe, ça pousse les journalistes locaux
à me regarder à travers un prisme étrange.
J'ai vu des comptes rendus à mon sujet qui m'ont beaucoup surprise. Comme cette chaîne, Arte, ils ont fait
- Fais attention avec tes cheveux (micro)
- Désolée
Quel type de reportage bizarre ils ont fait, Arte, sur vous ? Ils vous ont décrit comment ?
Comme quelqu'un de sulfureux qui sentait le souffre ? Un agent secret du FSB ?
Tout à fait. Certains disent le FSB, d'autres disent le KGB qui n'existe plus. Mais oui, c'est vrai, c'est l'image que que j'ai ici.
D'un coté c'est vraiment drôle et on peut en rire mais d'un autre côté, je pense que
c'est une vision très archaïque, comme un relent de guerre froide.
Est-ce que vous avez été approchée par les services de renseignement russes, que ce soit sur votre territoire ou sur notre territoire ?
Non, jamais.
Est-ce que vous avez été approchée par les services de renseignements français, ou est-ce que vous avez détecté une écoute à votre encontre ?
Puisque je ne suis pas une spécialiste, je ne suis pas sûre d'être en mesure de vous dire si je suis surveillée ou sur écoute. Mais on m'a dit que je l'étais.
C'est une réponse que quelqu'un du FSB aurait pu me faire.
Oui forcément. Et je ne le suis pas, je ne suis rattachée à aucun service secret.
Une petite question d'internet pour faire transition : est-ce qu'il y a à vos yeux des médias français que vous trouvez fiables ou intéressants ?
Je suis toujours en train d'apprendre autant que je peux depuis que je suis arrivée il y a un peu plus de 6 mois, vous savez, et je m'intéresse à différents médias.
Je dirais que je lis Le Monde Diplomatique avec intérêt puisque c'est un média qui analyse beaucoup les sujets internationaux, ce qui est très rare en France.
A côté de ça, je dirais que je n'ai pas de préférence. Je m'informe en ligne sur différents sites.
Comme celui sur lequel nous nous trouvons actuellement, qui est très intéressant. J'apprécie le fait que vous laissiez du temps et que vous ne coupiez pas les réponses.
J'ai aussi jeté un œil à certains projets intéressants sur les réseaux sociaux, comme Brut.
Mais d'une manière générale, je ne dirais pas qu'il y a un média dont je suis pleinement satisfaite. J'espère qu'RT France va en devenir un.
Est-ce que vous avez des amis Français ?
- Oui.
- Beaucoup ?
Pas énormément pour l'instant, mais j'en ai quelques uns. Vous savez, pour nous les russes, ça prend toujours du temps.
- Vous avez voyagé dans notre pays ?
- Un peu, oui
- Où ça ?
Je suis allée dans le sud de la France plusieurs fois. Je suis allée à Marseille quand je suis arrivée, j'y ai passé un long week-end
pendant lequel j'ai pu parcourir les Calanques, c'était magnifique.
Quel est votre avis sur la population française ?
Très divers je dois dire. J'avais un point de vue avant de venir en France, et j'en ai un autre maintenant
J'attends les deux, je vous écoute.
Avant de venir ici j'étais certaine que les français étaient très ouverts, très diversifiés dans leurs opinions
prêt à débattre avec vous tout en vous accordant de l'espace de parole pour vos idées.
J'ai appris que ce n'était pas toujours le cas.
C'était une attente qui ne correspond pas vraiment à la réalité.
Il y a encore beaucoup de gens qui réfléchissent et qui sont prêts à débattre avec vous. Mais également des gens qui n'ont pas le désir de regarder en dehors du cadre habituel.
Je crois que ça arrive dans beaucoup de pays. Ce n'est pas spécifique à la France. C'est l'époque dans laquelle nous vivons.
Les gens sont un peu fermés, et peut-être victimes d'un lavage de cerveau médiatique aussi.
C'est un monopole qui est en train de se perdre ?
- Qu'entendez-vous par là ?
- Le monopole de la vérité.
Il y en a ? Il y en a déjà eu ? Je veux dire, de la vérité en général.
Bonne réponse ! Question d'internet : que pense-t-elle de France 24, est-ce que c'est l'équivalent de RT ?
Le mode de financement est le même. En ce qui concerne la ligne éditoriale, pas du tout.
Je pense que
Nous sommes presque toujours appelés "la chaîne du Kremlin"
"La chaîne de Poutine"... mais le fait que nous soyons financés par l'état russe ce n'est pas exceptionnel.
France24, que vous avez mentionné, est financée par l'Etat français.
Et BBC World est directement financé par le ministère des affaires étrangères.
Vous avez aussi Al Jazeera, Deutsche Welle...
donc il y a beaucoup de modèles, de chaînes qui sont financées par des Etats.
La différence entre eux et nous est que nous nous considérons nous-même comme un média alternatif.
Ça signifie que nous sommes toujours attentifs
et que nous remettons en question tous les articles que nous publions.
Pour nous, c'est beaucoup de travail, et c'est un travail quotidien
de nous assurer que nous ne nous limitons pas nous-mêmes,
et de mettre en perspective les différents points de vue et leur permettre de s'exprimer.
Est-ce que vous avez l'impression que vous vous faites le travail de nos journalistes,
ici, au sein de nos frontières ?
Et est-ce que vous avez l'impression que nos journalistes font votre travail, au sein de l'Etat russe ?
Non.
Non, pas du tout,
et je vais vous dire pourquoi.
Je pense
qu'en France, nous plaçons la barre plus haut pour les journalistes locaux.
Nous sommes comme une sorte de douche froide, vous savez...
Nous ne laissons pas les journalistes se reposer
sur des sujets qui sont vraiment importants, maintenant que nous sommes là.
Lesquels sont importants ?
Eh bien, les sujets qui souvent ne sont pas couverts.
Pour parler de l'actualité internationale, j'ai vu des exemples de couverture sur la Syrie
qui étaient extrêmement biaisées.
Et je pense que, vous savez, en étant là... enfin, en nous donnant la parole avec un autre point de vue,
cela oblige en quelque sorte les médias locaux à entrer aussi dans cette perspective.
Cela sera difficile pour eux d'omettre de parler de ces problèmes.
En ce qui concerne la Russie, je ne dirai pas la même chose. Parce que je ne pense pas que
les journalistes étrangers fassent du bon boulot.
Je pense qu'ils aident à maintenir cette image très négative de la Russie.
Quand on parle de la politique intérieure russe, c'est très biaisé.
Nous allons bientôt avoir nos élections, cette année.
Et le fait que Vladimir Poutine bénéficie d'un large soutien de la part des Russes
n'est jamais vraiment rapporté de cette manière.
Mais il y a une grosse couverture médiatique de ses opposants, comme Alexei Navalny.
Ce que je vois c'est qu'ils se concentrent sur cette seule personne et ne donnent pas l'intégralité de l'histoire.
Pourquoi les russes préfèrent Poutine, pourquoi il ne sont pas pour Navalny.
Et j'ai eu ce cas très intéressant dans notre salle de rédaction.
Lorsque nous traitions des opposants politiques à Vladimir Poutine et que je me suis rendue compte
que toutes les infos que nous, ici à RT France, recevions, provenaient de l'AFP.
Et dans ses dépêches, l'AFP considérait Navalny comme le principal opposant à Vladimir Poutine.
Mais la vérité, c'est que sa popularité n'est que de 1%, ce qui est moins que les communistes.
Mais il y a des choses dont les médias étrangers ne veulent pas parler, parce que c'est bien mieux
de vendre une image de répression.
Vous avez l'impression que c'est une ingérence extérieure ?
Eh bien ce n'est pas une impression, c'est un fait. Beaucoup de médias étrangers font des reportages
en russe, tous les jours, en disant que les Russes devraient faire une révolution
et renverser le gouvernement.
Les américains le font en permanence et n'ont pas arrêté depuis la chute de l'URSS.
Est-ce que vous avez l'impression que eux vous perçoivent comme une ingérence extérieure
parce que eux font ça chez vous ?
Oui, je le pense, oui. C'est le côté amusant. Il y a là un peu deux poids deux mesures.
Ce dont nous sommes accusés est en fait ce qu'ils font depuis des années.
Et il y a trop de tentatives d'influences externes envers la politique russe, principalement par les USA.
Quand on entend nous Français qu'il est très difficile d'être journaliste en Russie,
parce qu'il y a des pressions de l'Etat, que l'Etat fait peut-être assassiner des journalistes...
Vous avez un avis là-dessus ?
Je pense que c'est une fausse impression que les médias aiment à diffuser, que si vous êtes journaliste
en Russie, vous ne pouvez pas vous permettre de dire quoi que ce soit contre le gouvernement.
Ce qui n'est absolument pas vrai, vous savez. La quantité de médias qui critiquent le gouvernement
de manière quotidienne est importante.
En fait, bien plus qu'en France.
Honnêtement, pendant la campagne électorale, quand j'ai vu la quantité de couvertures positives sur E. Macron,
particulièrement pendant les quelques jours qui ont précédé l'élection et pendant les jours
de silence électoral, comme je crois qu'ils sont appelés ici, des appels clairs au vote en faveur d'E. Macron.
Et j'ai été très surprise parce que cela allait à l'encontre des règles ! Vous ne faites pas ça, pas vrai ?
Surtout durant les jours qui précèdent l'élection.
Alors non, de mon point de vue, c'est totalement exagéré. Et comme je l'ai dit,
il y a beaucoup de critiques du gouvernement qui sont émises par les médias russes.
Si je voulais dire quelque chose à ce propos, ou si quelqu'un voulait dire quelque chose de mal
ou de critique à l'encontre de Poutine, je ne me retrouverais pas immédiatement en prison
comme ce que l'on peut lire ou entendre dans les médias.
J'ai vu et j'ai entendu dire que les activistes écologistes en Russie étaient un petit peu réprimés
pour leurs reportages, tant sur les sous-marins nucléaires qui étaient en train de pourrir
dans la Mer du Nord... Dans ce qui a été filmé comme des décharges de sous-marins nucléaire à ciel ouvert.
Est-ce que vous en avez entendu parler ?
Non, en fait je ne suis pas capable de commenter cela, car je n'ai pas suivi cette histoire.
Pour être tout à fait honnête avec vous.
Ben, j'espère bien !
Question d'internet. Le polonium sur les journalistes russes ? Vous en avez entendu parler ?
Le polonium ? Pouvez-vous répéter la question ?
La question, c'est est-ce que vous avez déjà entendu parler du polonium qui est un agent radioactif
qui permet de développer un cancer très rapidement et de ne pas laisser de traces facilement.
Est-ce que vous en avez déjà entendu parler ?
Pas vraiment, non. Nous n'avons pas parlé de cela. Et la plus grosse histoire relative au polonium
que tout le monde connaît serait celle d'Alexandre Litvinenko en Angleterre, qui était aussi une histoire
pleine de controverses. C'était dépeint de façon unilatérale par les médias dominants,
et de manière assez différente dans les médias russes.
Est-ce qu'on vous a déjà censurés avec RT ?
Par Emmanuel Macron, oui.
Par Emmanuel Macron ?
Et dans d'autres pays aussi ou pas ?
Oui, aux USA, RT America a été qualifié "d'agent de l'étranger" récemment, et cela a créé beaucoup
de problèmes pour nos journalistes.
Désormais, ils doivent mentionner sur chaque production qu'ils réalisent que cela a été fait
par un agent étranger. Et évidemment ce n'est pas attractif pour de nouvelles recrues.
Cela crée beaucoup de problèmes, et je pense que la seule raison pour laquelle ça a été fait réside dans
l'importance qu'a pris RT aux USA. Beaucoup d'audience, surtout en ligne et sur les réseaux sociaux.
Et c'est quelque chose dont le gouvernement ne veut pas.
Votre position quand Twitter ou Facebook
vous déréférencent, vous empêchent de sponsoriser vos publications ?
Ça vous emmène à développer quel type de stratégie pour bloquer ça ?
C'est injuste de la part de réseaux sociaux comme Twitter de bloquer nos pub.
Et vous savez, plus tard, il y a eu un rapport déclarant "en fait, RT n'a transgréssé aucune règle".
Donc, à nouveau, il y a deux poids deux mesures.
RT fait très attention à la façon d'utiliser les réseaux sociaux.
Nous savons comment utiliser ces réseaux puisque nous nous y sommes intéressés depuis le tout début.
Donc nous utilisons Twitter pour tweeter, YouTube pour poster nos vidéos... et on le fait bien.
Et je pense que c'est parce que nous sommes bons que nous sommes censurés d'une certaine facon, et que certains essaient de nous arrêter.
Y'a ton coude qui frotte sur le... (microphone)
Quand tu fais ces gestes je flippe à mort ; qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'il se passe ?
Non, y a pas besoin d'avoir peur.
Donc, revenons à nos moutons.
Vous êtes très forts pour avoir l'opinion publique
sur vos réseaux sociaux, et vous avez une stratégie numérique qui est très efficace.
Et je suis d'accord avec vous, les média traditionnels, que ce soit américains, anglais ou français,
sont complètement largués par rapport à leur stratégie numérique.
Est-ce que vous avez fait exprès
au sein de votre chaîne Youtube RT France de faire des sujets un peu plus légers,
comme par exemple la petite fille russe qui tire des voitures avec ses cheveux, ou des choses comme ça,
pour ramener de l'audience sur votre chaîne Youtube ?
Nous, on appelle ça des Putaclic, des publications putaclic, "clickbait".
Est-ce que c'est fait exprès ?
Ou est-ce que c'est une nouvelle très très intéressante qu'une petite fille tire une voiture avec ses cheveux ?
Ok, donc il y a différentes catégories de public sur un média social,
et nous essayons de contenter ce public dans toute sa diversité
Ça s'est toujours passé comme ça. Pour atteindre les KPI, vous devez
publier des choses très intéressantes et
publier des faits divers qui sont intéressants pour
ces gens qui ne sont pas intéressés par la politique.
Mais il y a également des sujets politiques ou sociaux qui sont intéressants
pour une autre part de notre audience
Nous essayons de ne pas nous limiter.
S'il y a un contenu sympa et qui génère beaucoup de clics
et il n'y a aucun message politique ou social, c'est cool, c'est viral.
Pourquoi ne pas les mettre en ligne ?
Bien sûr ça aide à agrandir notre audience,
mais c'est le but des réseaux sociaux.
Certains nous suivront dans le but de regarder ces videos sympas et virales.
Mais certains n'iront voir que nos articles sur les problèmes géopolitiques,
ou sur l'approfondissement de leur sujet de prédilection,
ou encore sur le fil des sujets du jour.
Parce qu'en tant que nouveau média, nous suivons le flux d'information, nous suivons le planning...
et nous réagissons au jour le jour à ce qu'il se passe.
Est-ce que vous utilisez des utilitaires pour connaitre votre communauté ou votre audience ?
Est-ce que vous avez des petits programmes qui vous disent
"Voilà, vous avez tel % qui a tel âge, tel % qui a tel type d'opinion politique" ?
Qu'est-ce que vous utilisez ?
Nous n'utilisons pas vraiment cela.
Nous gardons un oeil dessus parce qu'il y a toujours des nouveaux outils statistiques.
Sur Google par exemple, vous avez les Google Analytics, les Youtube Analytics...
Nous tendons à suivre les positions géographiques.
Ça aide vraiment,
et je ne parle pas seulement de RT France mais aussi de RT Monde,
nous pouvons voir les régions où nos contenus sont les plus lus ou regardés.
C'est important d'avoir les bonnes personnes
et un social media manager,
si ils ont cet manne de connaissance, c'est un avantage
c'est un avantage parce que nous pouvons un peu améliorer ou modifier légèrement notre contenu
pour le rendre plus intéressant et plus attractif.
Je pense que c'est une chose dont les médias traditionnels manquent.
Comprendre ce que leur public veut vraiment.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils attendent de nous ?
Nous essayons de les écouter.
On vous reproche souvent
d'avoir comme audience une audience d'extrême droite.
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez répondre à ça ?
Bien, comme je l'ai dit, je continue de dire
que classer notre site à l'extrême droite est une accusation sans aucun fondement
Pendant la campagne électorale, nous avons couvert
tous les candidats,
et nous avons voulu donner autant d'espace à JL. Mélenchon
que nous en avons donné à M. Le Pen.
Et E. Macron a probablement eu la plus grande partie de notre espace pendant la campagne,
même si nous n'avons jamais eu la permission de rentrer dans son QG de campagne.
Je pense qu'en tant que média
n'ayant pas l'obligation
de soutenir une puissance politique ou une autre en France,
nous sommes bien plus libres
de couvrir les choses de manière équilibrée.
On doit admettre que
la France est un pays hétérogène.
Nous devons respecter les gens de droite ou de gauche, ça n'a pas d'importance.
On est reparti.
Infiniment désolé pour cette petite coupure, on a changé d'émetteur pour le micro.
Je vais poser comme ça une question d'internet :
"RT est l'objet d'attaques violentes de nos dirigeants.
Attends...
qu'est-ce que ça dit de nos politiques selon Madame Federova ?"
Les attaques que vous subissez
par nos politiques, par nos dirigeants sont très très agressives,
vous,
votre interprétation de leurs attaques c'est :
par peur ?
Par le fait de vous disqualifier ?
Quelle interprétation vous avez de ces attaques là ?
J'ai compris, merci.
Je pense que c'est un peu de tout ça.
Et...
Ou peut-être beaucoup de ce dont vous venez de parler.
Je pense
que la 1ère raison pour eux est de nous empêcher
d’accroître notre audience et devenir plus populaires.
Ça pourrait aussi être, selon moi,
le souhait de plus de contrôle du gouvernement sur ce que les médias disent.
Ne pas laisser aux médias trop d'ouverture,
de libertés, ne pas être trop critiques sur ce qui arrive
et les impacts de certaines décisions du gouvernement.
Je pense que nous sommes une très bonne raison
de commencer une guerre
contre ce qui est appelé "fake news",
mais la vraie raison serait en fait les journalistes français,
le journalisme et la liberté d'expression. Et je pense que
si ça se passe ainsi et si des lois spéciales sont imposées
et créées par des organisations à but non lucratif,
nous devrions nous pencher sur la façon dont elles sont financées en premier lieu et qui se tient derrière elles.
Je pense que c'est le premier pas vers plus de censure.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez du Décodex ?
Bien, vous savez, la plateforme qui s'occupe de
discréditer les fake news, c'est ça ?
De la même manière que RT vérifient les faits,
quelque chose comme ça... "Fact check" !
Donc qu'est-ce que vous pensez du Décodex, l'équivalent de votre Fact Check ?
Je l'ai regardé plusieurs fois et je pense que c'est juste une autre manière
de diffuser les fake news.
Pour vous c'est une nouvelle façon d’essaimer des fake news ?
Pour le Décodex, j'ai vu plusieurs...
Enfin, il suffit de prendre un exemple et il ne sera pas corroboré par des faits.
Donc ça pourrait être une bonne plate forme pour discréditer les fake news,
mais il n'y a pas assez d'informations pour démontrer clairement qu'il s'agit bien de fake news.
Je pense que c'est un problème général, plus grand,
car désormais la guerre des fakes news est tellement tendance.
On sait que Trump utilise ça souvent en ce moment.
Dès qu'il y a un problème, c'est une fake news.
Mais personne n'a de définition claire de ce que c'est.
Qui prend la décision de ce qui est vrai ou faux ?
Et, vous savez, il y a beaucoup de plateformes qui émergent
en disant que c'est elles qui connaissent la vérité
et les gens voudraient vraiment y croire.
Parce que les gens veulent savoir ce qui est vrai et ce qui ne l'est pas.
Vous savez, ils veulent croire qu'ils ont une source crédible.
Mais en réalité je pense que ça ne marche pas vraiment pour l'instant.
Vous avez des pistes, des solutions pour améliorer ça ?
Vous feriez quoi, vous ?
Bien, dans notre cas,
voilà ce que nous faisons : nous contrôlons deux fois les faits
et quand ils sont confirmés et avérés,
c'est ce sur quoi nous nous appuyons,
c'est le principe premier pour créer notre contenu quotidiennement.
Et avec le CSA,
qui est très attentif à ce que nous faisons,
nous vérifions en fait 3 fois pour ne pas laisser la moindre place à la moindre petite erreur
qui pourrait être exagérée.
Question d'internet :
RT prétend-il comme la plupart de nos médias
d'information d'être neutre, objectif, ou assume-t-il sa partialité et son orientation ?
Merci. Pour la prochaine, si vous pouviez parler un peu plus fort, ça m'aiderait davantage.
Oh, ils ont changé la voix (ndt : traduction français -> russe)
RT milite pour des actualités et des sujets qui sont couverts sous toutes les perspectives.
Pour nous, c'est aussi important
parce que nous avons des valeurs, et nos valeurs sont de couvrir le sujet et de montrer l'envers du décors.
Les mêmes valeurs que la charte de Munich?
J'espère que oui !
Dans notre cas, il s'agit plutôt de donner la parole aux voix qui sont réduites au silence.
Je ne dirais pas que c'est la même chose, c'est plutôt que...
Vous ne verrez pas ça sur CNN,
vous ne verrez pas cela sur les médias grand public,
mais vous le verrez sur RT et c'est pourquoi ça que ça marche,
c'est l'analyse qui est derrière tout ça.
Pour nous, il est vraiment important de suivre cette logique, cette valeur, et d'être
d'être dignes de confiance
parce que nous avons notre public, et qu'il s'agit des gens qui en ont assez
de voir partout le même point de vue sur les événements.
Nous savons qu'il y en a plus et que nous devons nous interroger d'avantage.
Et nous sommes la plate-forme vers laquelle vous allez vous tourner
pour vérifier si c'est le cas ou non.
Je dirais donc
que nous aimerions être cette partie manquante du puzzle,
mais avec nous, le puzzle devient complet.
Donc je ne dirais pas :
"Regardez RT juste parce que nous sommes les seuls à vous dire
l'unique et absolue vérité".
Je dirais qu'il faut regarder RT si quelque chose vous échappe,
si vous avez l'impression qu'on ne vous dit pas toute la vérité,
que vous avez été induit en erreur par les médias grand public.
Alors vous devriez passer à RT.
Vous avez un avis sur Sputnik en France?
Je pense qu'ils qu'ils travaillent très dur.
Nous sommes différents et ça a un sens,
parce que leurs KPI sont différents des nôtres ;
nous sommes une chaîne de télévision, ils sont un site web et une station de radio,
donc je pense que ce n'est pas la même chose.
Ils sont parrainés par l'État, par la Russie,
donc nous sommes presque toujours confondus comme étant la même organisation,
ce que nous ne sommes pas.
Et c'est comme avoir ce grand groupe de médias
et ses différents canaux, différentes parties qui ne sont pas connectées les unes aux autres
et qui ont peut-être même une ligne éditoriale différente.
Mais, pour faire une remarque,
ils sont aussi oppressés que nous
et pour cela, nous estimons que c'est tout à fait injuste.
Vous avez 20 millions d'euros par an pour faire fonctionner votre chaine de Télé,
vous comptez avoir une augmentation de budget ? C'est trop ? C'est pas assez ?
Vous en êtes où à Boulogne là ?
Vous êtes à Boulogne, vos locaux sont dans le 92 c'est ça ?
Non, pas vraiment.
Donc, on ne devrait pas considérer le budget comme énorme
parce que quand on parle du lancement d'une chaîne d'infos,
ça veut dire qu'il faut acheter beaucoup d'équipements coûteux, donc...
Imaginez : il faut avoir le bâtiment, les travaux,
construire les 2 studios, équiper les 2 studios avec ce matériel cher
qui coûte parfois des millions d'euros, c'est fou, non ?
Je dirais que
nous en avons juste assez pour lancer
et accomplir ce que nous devions faire,
et ce n'est pas le même budget pour l'année prochaine,
ça sera moins.
Si vous comparez notre budget avec d'autres chaînes,
même par rapport aux chaînes françaises,
c'est deux fois moins que certaines chaînes françaises,
que la plupart des chaînes françaises..
Je pense donc que nous...
Nous essayons de réduire les dépenses autant que possible
et c'est sûr que nous dépensons pas à l’excès.
Nous sommes également heureux de partager les ressources avec d'autres chaînes de RT,
puisque nous avons RT en espagnol,
nous avons RT en arabe et nous avons RT International qui diffuse en anglais.
Pour Boulogne,
nous avons la chance d'avoir un très bel emplacement,
2 studios relativement petits,
1 pour l'actualité et 1 pour les émissions et les programmes,
et plusieurs bureaux.
C'est donc environ 1 500 m² au total
mais une fois qu'on y est, on se rend compte que c'est très...
joliment équipé mais n'avons pas l'impression d'avoir beaucoup d'espace.
Comment se passe une rédaction chez vous ?
Est-ce que vous avez,
on va dire d'une façon caricaturale,
est-ce que vous avez l'oeil de Moscou
qui regarde ce que vous faites
à chaque minute, chaque seconde ?
Combien de fois vous avez au téléphone votre maison-mère à Moscou ?
Est-ce que vous les avez tous les jours au téléphone
est-ce que vous avez une entière liberté dans votre prise de décision,
dans la façon que vous avez de traiter vos reportages ?
Oui, les décisions éditoriales sont prises en France,
à Boulogne, presque à Paris, à Boulogne,
par notre équipe.
Nous le faisons donc comme n'importe quelle autre chaîne,
nous nous réunissons pour les réunions de rédaction le matin, le jour, la nuit,
nous gardons le contact tout le temps,
nous avons les plannings, l'ordre du jour que nous suivons.
La chose la plus importante, je dirais,
c'est de s'assurer que nous regardons toujours de l'autre coté de l'histoire.
Donc nos producteurs, nos éditeurs,
ils doivent travailler autant... Deux fois plus
que n'importe quelle autre chaîne parce qu'ils cherchent toujours plus.
Ce que je vois assez souvent ici, c'est que
les chaînes françaises basent leur agenda sur des sources comme l'AFP.
Et d'autres nouvelles sources
répètent à peu près la même chose.
Pour nous, il est important d'être différents.
Il n' y a pas d'appels du Kremlin,
Vladimir Poutine ne m'appelle pas tous les jours, même pas une fois par an.
Il vous appelle tout les combien de temps ? Tous les trois ans ?
J'aurais aimé pouvoir dire qu'il m'appelle, mais ce n'est pas le cas.
Vous avez voté pour qui aux dernières élections ?
Pour lui.
Parce que j'ai un souvenir très frais de ce qui se passait dans mon pays
pendant les années 90.
Racontez-moi !
Je pense qu'il serait difficile pour vous de comprendre toute l'étendue des dommages
causés par Eltsine et les oligarques.
Après la chute de l'Union soviétique,
la Russie était très ouverte à l'Occident,
en particulier aux États-Unis,
très ouverte à l'idée d'essayer d'arranger les choses,
d'essayer d'être le gentil garçon.
Se rattraper avec tout ce que l'Union soviétique a fait dans le passé.
En gros, nous suivions la voie de l'Ouest.
Tant et si bien que cela allait parfois à l'encontre de nos intérêts,
des intérêts de notre pays.
Je me souviens de ce qu'étaient les années 90 : nous avions...
des prix fous, des criminels, la mafia, le terrorisme...
Suicides.
Je pense que le pays avait l'impression qu'il était en train de s'effondrer.
Et il était vraiment dangereux d'aller dans la rue.
Je me souviens que ma mère ne me laissait pas sortir pour voir mes amis,
parce qu'elle avait peur que je sois enlevée et qu'elle doive me racheter en morceaux.
Je dirais donc qu'avec Vladimir Poutine, les choses se sont vraiment améliorées pour les Russes.
et que le pays, maintenant, se sent beaucoup plus fort qu'il ne l'était avant,
que son estime de soi est revenue...
Nous avions été très déçus par les États-Unis
quand ils ont bombardé la Yougouslavie
contre toutes les règles, contre
la loi, contre les résolutions des Nations Unies
et cela a été un grand choc pour nous tous.
Donc, je pense que c'est là que les Russes ont commencé à changer de mentalité
et à repenser à nous-mêmes,
ne pas essayer d'être les gentils gars et plaire aux États-Unis
autant que nous le faisions auparavant.
Vous connaissez la Serbie ?
Je n'y ai pas été personnellement,
mais j'ai des amis Serbes, et la Serbie et la Russie sont assez proches
de par leur religion,
et ils sont considérés comme étant très très proches
donc c'était très préoccupant pour nous de voir un pays européen se faire bombarder.
Vous êtes religieuse, vous avez une religion, vous avez un ami imaginaire ou vous êtes complètement athée ?
Je suis orthodoxe russe et vous devez comprendre que l'Union soviétique était contre la religion.
Elle n'était pas illégale mais ce n'était pas vraiment populaire.
Et je le suis néanmoins... Je crois en Dieu. Mais je ne suis pas très religieuse, donc je ne vais pas à la messe.
Mais en grandissant, j'ai décidé de m'engager. Et puisque mon pays est orthodoxe, j'ai décidé d'aller vers ça.
Je pense vraiment qu'il faut réellement avoir de bonnes raisons pour être athée,
parce qu'il y a tellement de choses qu'on ignore et qu'on n'est pas capable d'expliquer.
Et je ne dirais pas que je suis religieuse au sens propre mais je crois en Dieu
et dans le fait que les choses ne sont pas aussi simples qu'elles peuvent en avoir l'air.
Une question d'internet : soutiendrait-elle un média financé par l'Union Européenne,
et qui s'installerait en Russie pour faire comme RT ?
Ceci est-il autorisé par la loi Russe ?
Pourrait-il ouvrir une chaîne télé ?
Je la laisse traduire.
Encore une fois, je ne suis pas habilitée à parler pour le gouvernement russe sur ce point
mais ce que je peux vous dire c'est que beaucoup de médias ont des antennes en russe
par exemple BBC a une antenne
et ils mettent en ligne des nouvelles quotidiennes en langue russe
Deutsche Welle a également un service en langue russe
RFI a aussi une antenne en russe
tout comme Voice of America qui continue d'exister en russe.
Donc sur les nouvelles du jour
la cible principale est de...
l'objectif principal est de viser le gouvernement et
toutes les publications qui sont diffusées sur internet en russe
sont contre le gouvernement russe en place.
Et ils sont toujours opérationnels.
Ça renforce l'opinion publique Russe pour soutenir Vladimir Poutine ?
Est-ce que c'est contre-productif de faire ça ?
Est-ce que c'est de la propagande à la papa ?
Est-ce que c'est de la propagande de l'ancien temps en Russie, mais les Russes,
comme,
ils ont évolués plus rapidement que l'opinion...
Du moins l'opinion publique Russe a évolué plus rapidement que l'opinion publique internationale par rapport à ce type de sujet parce qu'ils avaient déjà subis ce type de propagande.
A l'ère de l'ex Union Soviétique, est-ce qu'ils sont...
Est-ce que ces positions des médias occidentaux en Russie
renforcent l'opinion publique Russe ?
Je pense que c'est très dur de
manipuler l'esprit des Russes.
Simplement parce que nous avons une bonne expérience
et non pas parce que nous serions plus forts.
Je pense que nous avons eu une très bonne expérience
de vivre pendant l'Union Soviétique, nous savons
comment cela fonctionne vous savez, nous l'avons expérimenté de manière quotidienne.
Et à un moment de l'Histoire tout le monde savait ce qui se passait. Pour nous, maintenant,
nous prenons les choses avec beaucoup de scepticisme.
Il y a beaucoup d'efforts pour
pour nous dire comment nous devrions vivre.
Mais je pense que les Russes sont désormais très méfiants sur ce point.
Et ils ont tendance à avoir leur propres conclusions.
Pourtant, même s'il n'y a pas de place,
d'un autre côté il y a aussi beaucoup de nouvelles technologies
qui peuvent être utilisé pour viser une audience plus jeune
pour amener ce sentiment de rébellion.
D'insatisfaction.
Il y a toujours des gens réceptifs à cela parce que les choses peuvent toujours être améliorées
et devraient être améliorées.
En Russie, quand vous avez une chaîne Youtube par exemple,
et que vous avez plus de 3000 followers,
vous êtes obligés de vous déclarer comme média.
En France ce n'est pas le cas.
Est ce que vous pensez que...
c'est une position trop dure du gouvernement Russe face aux blogueurs, ou est-ce que c'est tout à fait normal ?
Je pense plutôt que
c'est un moyen d'éviter
une situation dangereuse
parce que....
comment dire....
- Vous parlez des flashmobs ? C'est ça ?
- Non, non, non.
Je parles parle plus de comportements extrêmes comme
le propagation du terrorisme qui est un grand danger pour la Russie.
La communauté sur internet est une bonne plateforme pour répandre
ce genre d'idées radicales.
Nous avons toujours des compatriotes russes qui combattent avec l'Etat Islamique en Syrie et des choses comme cela...
Je pense que c'est plus que l'Etat
essaie de garder le contrôle sur
quoi et qui diffusent ce genre d'idées.
Je pense que ça vient de là.
Mais, je suis personnellement contre toute forme de censure.
Et je pense que c'est contre productif d'essayer de réguler internet.
Une autre question d'internet :
Comment RT se prépare-t-elle aux procès et aux injonctions qu'elle ne manquera pas de recevoir de la part du CSA,
des politiques et des autres médias à la moindre incartade
style accusation de fake news et ingérence ?
Vous avez un département juridique,
vous avez quelque chose autour de ça ?
Oui, d'accord. C'est une très bonne question, merci.
On nous accuse constamment de diffuser de la désinformation
mais on ne nous donne aucun fait... pour le prouver.
Et nous avons pris plusieurs mesures pour étudier les mesures légales afin de pouvoir y répondre.
- Pour contre attaquer ?
- Exactement.
La question était donc de savoir si nous devions le faire immédiatement contre
En-Marche et l'équipe d'Emmanuel Macron,
devrions-nous cibler tous les médias ?
Ce qui se passe actuellement, c'est que chaque fois qu'il y a une fausse publication sur nous
dans les médias, nous les contactons immédiatement et ils peuvent corriger.
S'ils ne corrigent pas, nous demandons un droit de réponse.
S'ils ne nous donnent pas ce droit, nous les attaquerons sur un plan juridique.
J'étais beaucoup plus optimiste au début, et je pensais que les choses allaient s'améliorer.
Mais au fur et à mesure que nous avançons, je constate que les choses empirent dans ce sens,
et que nous subissons encore plus de pressions.
La semaine dernière, j'ai eu une conversation avec nos avocats.
- Lesquels ?
- Nous avons plusieurs cabinets avec lesquels nous travaillons
et nous sommes sur le point de choisir celui qui nous représentera pour ces objectifs particuliers.
Je ne peux donc pas vous donner le nom tout de suite,
mais une fois que nous aurons pris une décision, je pourrai vous en faire part.
Je défends la position qu'il faut que nous soyons plus durs vis à vis de notre réponse, et dès que...
Ça devient fatiguant.
Donc, la prochaine fois que les médias nous accusent, disons
de diffuser des informations sur les comptes off-shore de Macron, ce qui n'a jamais été le cas,
Nous allons les cibler sur le plan légal.
Une autre question d'internet : le réchauffement climatique, les crises énergétiques, l'intelligence artificielle, sont-ils au cœur des débats en Russie et sur RT ?
Si j'ai bien compris la question,
je pense que la Russie reste très dépendante du pétrole et du gaz.
C'est donc un sujet qui préoccupe beaucoup les Russes, c'est certain.
Sur RT, je pense que c'est un sujet qui serait très intéressant d'un point de vue économique,
et également d'un point de vue politique, et pas seulement par rapport à la Russie, mais en général
Si vous avez une crise énergétique, vous aimerez en parler.
Nous donnerons sans aucun doute la plate-forme et la parole aux experts
pour qu'ils viennent parler, discuter et expliquer ce qui vient en premier, ce qui vient ensuite.
Je veux dire qu'il n' y a pas de sujets que nous censurerions ou n'aurions pas sur RT.
Et c'est encore une fois cette idée erronée que nous ne serions pas critiques.
Je pense qu'en ce qui concerne la Russie, nous couvrons beaucoup de sujets.
La vérité, c'est que nous sommes ici plus pour couvrir des sujets internationaux
que pour nous concentrer uniquement sur la Russie, mais nous couvrons aussi des sujets Russes
et nous invitons les gens qui critiquent beaucoup la Russie, qui critiquent beaucoup le gouvernement.
Cela a toujours été comme ça.
Nous avons couvert des manifestations quand cela arrive, dans les rues de Moscou, de Saint-Pétersbourg.
Et mieux que ça, nous les avons couvertes en direct.
Nous les avons donc diffusées en direct sur nos médias sociaux, sur notre site Web.
Et je préférerais la partie live parce que de cette façon, vous avez une vue d'ensemble, vous avez le tableau réel.
J'ai vu tellement de fois CNN, BBC, monter les histoires comme ils le voulaient
pour qu'il y ait une exagération ou une sous-représentation de certains événements.
Donc pour nous, il n'y a pas de tabou, vraiment.
La seule chose contre laquelle je suis, c'est que les journalistes soient les juges.
Vous voyez, nous ne sommes pas ici pour juger, nous sommes ici pour couvrir ces actualités.
Et il revient aux spectateurs de décider et de tirer une conclusion sur ce qu'ils ressentent
et sur ce qu'ils préfèrent défendre.
Mais pour les journalistes, il est important de donner les faits.
Oui, de donner les analyses, de donner la parole à des opinions différentes. Oui !
Mais pas d'être ceux qui jugent. Cela arrive souvent en France.
Est-ce que vous allez dans des think tanks ?
Est-ce que vous-mêmes vous faites partie d'un think tank de journaliste par exemple,
un think tank qui traiterait des affaires économiques, ou des affaires énergétiques, ou un think tank ayant une spécialité comme le terrorisme.
Est-ce que vous, vous fréquentez, travaillez dans un think tank, dans un groupe de travail ?
Est-ce que vous développez votre propre prisme de lecture
sur la géopolitique, sur le terrorisme, des sujets importants ?
Ou est-ce que vous faites simplement votre travail de collecte d'information ?
Quand tu dis "vous", tu veux dire "RT" ?
- Non, toi.
- Ok. Non, je fais mon travail de journaliste.
Je ne fais partie d'aucun think tank.
Et j'aimerais garder les choses comme ça,
parce que je pense qu'une fois que vous rejoignez un think tank,
vous devenez un peu partial.
Je préfère donc rester dans mon cadre pour le moment.
- Qu'est-ce que vous pensez des journalistes qui sont invités par exemple
au Dîner du Siècle,
qui est un think tank influent en France,
à la Commission Trilatérale ?
Est-ce que vous pensez qu'il faut mettre une grande distance entre
la profession de journaliste et les cercles d'influence ?
Vous venez de nous le dire, mais...
Ok, je voulais juste m'assurer que j'avais bien compris.
Comme je l'ai dit, je ne pense pas qu'un journaliste devrait faire partie de groupes de réflexion.
On doit couvrir le travail de ces think tanks,
et questionner ce que sont ces organisations,
d'où ils sont financés,
par qui et où sont les racines ?
Parce qu'on voit de nombreux think tanks très puissants.
Il y en a des petits, mais certains sont vraiment puissants
Lesquels ?
Je ne vous donnerai pas les exemples exacts tout de suite, mais je dirais,
disons, toute organisation qui est supposée suivre
une certaine idée, mais qui se perd un peu en chemin.
Les ONG aussi.
Je suis très curieuse de ce que les Reporters Sans Frontières font en France.
J'ai eu l'opportunité de
rencontrer le responsable de l'organisation ici.
C'était juste après
qu'il y avait eu quelques échanges entre RT et RSF.
Comme vous le savez peut-être, RSF affirme que RT est un ennemi du journalisme.
Et de notre côté, nous pensons que RSF sont supposés être ceux qui protègent les journalistes.
L'équipe et les reporters de RT risquent leurs vies
en allant dans des zones qui ne sont vraiment pas sécurisées.
Nous avons perdu une personne en Syrie.
Plusieurs de nos gars ont été blessés en Ukraine.
C'est totalement cynique de la part d'une organisation
supposée combattre pour les droits des journalistes
de proclamer que nous n'en sommes pas.
C'est allé plus loin que ça,
et de ce que nous avons appris,
ils vont avoir un rôle important dans le développement de la nouvelle loi contre les fake news.
Cela m'inquiète beaucoup pour le futur.
- Il existe des think tanks de journalistes en Russie
- Il y en a plusieurs.
Vous pouvez nous en citer quelques uns ?
Il y a plusieurs organisations qui s'appellent Associations des Journalistes,
et elles sont...
- L'académie internationale de journalisme, télévision et radio, vous connaissez ?
- Oui, je connais un peu ces gars là.
Il y a aussi la Russian Union of Journalists.
Et l'idée est qu'une fois que vous en faites partie,
vous êtes d'une certaine manière protégé,
et vous discutez des sujets brûlants.
Ils sont censés observer les situations où les droits des journalistes sont bafoués.
C'est l'idée derrière ces think tanks et ces associations.
Mais encore une fois, pour aller au bout du raisonnement,
on voit à quel point une organisation qui est censée faire cela
devient très politique et adopte une certaine position,
ce qui, à mon avis, est une situation très dangereuse.
Autre question internet :
quels sont les projets de RT à long terme ?
Devenir un média mainstream
ou se poser en tant que voix alternative dans un système où l'information est questionnable ?
Je suis désolé, je ne l'entends pas très bien.
Donc peut-être pouvez-vous répéter la question en français ? Je vais le faire sans le...
- Quels sont les projets à long terme pour RT ?
- Ok, les projets à long terme.
- Devenir un media mainstream ?
- Devenir un média mainstream ?
- Ou se poser en tant que voix alternative
dans un système où l'information est questionnable ?
- Ok.
Donc...
Merci, merci, j'entends. Merci beaucoup.
C'est juste que c'est un peu confus quand je l'entends le dire, mais j'ai déjà compris.
De toute évidence, pour RT,
l'objectif n'est pas du tout d'être mainstream.
Ce serait la fin de RT, je dirais.
Donc pour nous, c'est complètement impossible à imaginer.
Je pense que nous voyons notre mission
comme quelque chose de plus grand que le simple témoignage du courant dominant.
Qu'est-ce que vous êtes prêts à sacrifier pour votre profession ?
Eh bien, c'est déjà le cas ?
- Vous vous sacrifiez, là ?
- Beaucoup, oui. Oui, bien sûr, bien sûr.
- Dites-moi ce que vous sacrifiez. J'ai bien une petite idée.
- Comme quoi ?
- On verra ça après.
- Je suis vraiment curieuse de savoir ce que vous alliez dire.
- Qu'est-ce que vous êtes prête à sacrifier ?
- On travaille beaucoup.
Et quand je dis beaucoup, c'est vraiment beaucoup.
Est-ce que vous êtes prête à perdre la vie ?
L'équilibre entre la vie et le travail est une chose que nous n'avons pas vraiment.
Parce que quand vous êtes
entièrement absorbé par le travail,
ça signifie qu'il peut arriver que vous n'ayez pas vraiment de jours de congés,
pas vraiment de week-ends libres. Vous n'avez pas vraiment de temps libre.
Il faut être là pour répondre et réagir,
surtout quand on travaille pour les chaines d'informations.
Vous savez, le temps est précieux.
Donc il faut y être. Et parfois, il est impossible de se déconnecter de ça. On vit vraiment comme ça.
Mais je ne me plains pas
parce qu'il y a des gens qui sacrifient tellement plus, comme Julian Assange, par exemple.
Comment pourrions-nous nous comparer
au vu des choses qu'il a du sacrifier pour ses idéaux et ses idées ?
Question d'internet :
est-ce que vous pouvez préciser la répartition des nationalités de RT France ?
Combien de Russes, combien de Français ?
Merci pour cette question.
Sur 150 personnes, 5 russes.
Mais les 5 sont à quels postes ?
Moi,
une fille qui travaille pour la gestion de bureau
elle aide à acheter des stylos, des papiers...
Elle a la clé du trésor, c'est ça ?
Non, non, non, elle fait juste...
Elle aide à fournir tout ce qui est nécessaire pour le travail de bureau.
Une fille qui travaille sur les risques et la conformité.
Quelqu'un qui travaillait avec moi à Berlin et qui m'a suivie à Paris.
Nous avons également un producteur
qui s'occupe de la coordination avec notre QG.
Ce qui fait trois.
Et un gars en informatique.
Est-ce que vous comptez faire des reportages à l'étranger pour RT France ?
Absolument, oui.
- Quels pays ?
- L'Afrique du Nord.
- Je dirais qu'on se pencherait vraiment sur les pays du Maghreb.
Nous souhaitons nous concentrer sur les territoires francophones.
Le Canada francophone, un jour.
C'est un peu trop loin pour le moment.
Nous aimerions aussi nous pencher sur le Moyen-Orient.
Je pense que c'est vraiment important. C'est une région intéressante
sur laquelle nous devons nous concentrer.
Et bien sûr, nous utiliserions les ressources de RT en Russie.
Nous avons une journaliste à Moscou
qui parle français, et elle fait les reportages pour nous sur
tout ce qui concerne la Russie ou les pays d'Asie Centrale.
Est-ce que vous êtes devenue journaliste à cause de votre maman ?
En gros, je pense que oui, en partie à cause d'elle.
Je pense qu'elle est un bon exemple, parce qu'elle était...
Elle a été et elle est celle qui a réussi à
garder la famille unie après le décès de mon père.
Et ce n'est pas facile quand on a 6 enfants.
Donc pour une femme qui a eu 6 enfants
et a dû travailler dur comme journaliste,
elle a de fait réussi à faire une carrière très intéressante.
Je pense que c'est un bon exemple de ce qu'une femme peut réaliser.
Comment vous avez financé vos études à Berlin?
Par moi-même. J'ai fait un emprunt
que je remboursais mensuellement.
Et à un moment, alors que je recevais mon salaire en roubles russes,
le rouble s'est effondré
et j'ai fini par ne plus pouvoir payer.
Donc ça m'a pris un moment
avant d'être en mesure de rembourser le prêt.
Mais c'était ma décision personnelle d'investir dans mon MBA.
Et ça a vraiment payé.
Ça m'a beaucoup aidé.
Entre vous et nous, comment vous voyez l'avenir ?
Entre moi et vous, et l'audience massive sur youtube vous voulez dire ?
Comment je vois le futur pour RT ?
Non. Comment vous voyez le futur pour nous tous ?
Est-ce qu'on va à la guerre ? Est-ce qu'on va vers plus de paix ? Vers plus de dialogue ?
Ou vers des ingérences à gauche et à droite, de la propagande à gauche et à droite,
avec un manque de communication entre les peuples ?
Ou est-ce qu'on va vers plus de communication
franche, honnête, précise ?
Je pense que nous sommes dans une situation très dangereuse, peut-être plus proche de la guerre
qu'on ne l'a jamais été depuis la Seconde Guerre Mondiale.
Et c'est très dangereux, en raison de l'incapacité des pays à s'écouter les uns les autres.
Et nous, en tant que journalistes, avons beaucoup de pression sur nos épaules,
nous devons être en mesure de donner du sens à ces informations en couvrant avec transparence
ce qui se passe dans le monde.
Est-ce que pour vous les journalistes portent une certaine responsabilité de ce climat ?
Absolument. Absolument, oui.
Si vous regardez comment les guerres commencent, il y a toujours une campagne massive des médias
pour soutenir l'idée de l'intervention.
Si vous regardez ce qui s'est passé en Irak, tous les fondements justifiant la campagne guerrière
ont été montés de toute pièce.
Et les armes de destruction massive n'ont jamais existé.
Pourtant, ça a été massivement diffusé par les médias.
Et je pense que ça arrive très, très souvent.
Est-ce que RT s'est déjà planté ? Est-ce que vous avez déjà sorti... si on peut parler trivialement...
Est-ce que vous avez déjà fait de la merde ?
Et quelle a été votre conduite introspective face à ça ?
Aucune organisation n'est à l'abri de faire des erreurs.
Surtout quand on a une nouvelle équipe ou une jeune équipe.
Quelqu'un qui ne croise pas ses sources, qui copie-colle une source qui n'est pas assez crédible.
C'est arrivé par le passé, ça arrivera dans le futur.
Tous les médias font des erreurs.
Parfois ce sont des erreurs bénignes, parfois des erreurs plus graves.
Et dans tous les cas, quand cela arrive, RT fait toujours un correctif et s'excuse pour
la désinformation que nous aurions pu causer en ne vérifiant pas à deux reprises la source.
C'est quelque chose que l'on fait toujours sur notre site web, et que nous ferons à l'antenne.
Parfois on se retrouve avec quelqu'un qu'on invite qui commence à parler de théories du complot.
et c'est une situation très délicate puisqu'on ne peut pas vraiment couper quelqu'un à l'antenne.
Est-ce qu'il y a une affaire dont on aurait honte ? Non.
Intentionnellement ? Non, je ne pense pas.
- Et pas intentionnellement ?
Est-ce que vous avez eu honte de certains trucs?
Non intentionnellement ? Ça peut arriver oui.
Comme je l'ai dit, ça peut arriver à tout le monde et...
Est-ce que c'est déjà arrivé ?
Au cours de ces 12 années ? Oui, à plusieurs reprises.
- Très peu de fois ?
A plusieurs reprises, au cours des 12 ans d'existence de RT. On a eu des soucis et des problèmes...
Vous vous rappelez quel sujet c'était ?
Eh bien, évidemment je ne me souviens pas des petites erreurs. Par contre, je dirais que la plus grosse
est quand on a dû arrêter une émission parce qu'on avait laissé la parole à un théoricien du complot qui affirmait
que le 11 septembre était un coup monté de l'intérieur.
- Lequel ?
Ça s'appelait "Le chercheur de vérité" et l'émission a été retirée de l'antenne.
La décision a été prise par notre rédactrice en chef.
Ce sont des choses qui arrivent, mais on assume toujours nos responsabilités.
Nous y portons une attention particulière.
Je me souviens d'une erreur purement technique quand on a diffusé des questions-réponses en direct
avec le Président Medvedev.
Vous dites que tout est questionnable.
Pourquoi est-ce que le 11 septembre ne le serait pas ?
RT a été présenté comme un fardeau par les Etats-Unis,
comme une plateforme destinée à répandre des fake news.
Donc nous devons être très prudents afin de ne pas perdre l'opportunité de diffuser nos contenus.
En conséquence, tout sujet qui pourrait être interprété comme une fake news est très épineux pour nous.
C'est une forme d'autocensure ?
C'est une pression qui pèse sur nous, oui, mais bon il faut pouvoir jauger la situation...
Est-ce que vous connaissez le projet Wikitribune ?
J'en ai un peu entendu parler, mais je ne pense pas être capable de vous en parler plus que ça.
Encore une question d'Internet : est-ce que vous êtes en contact avec Edward Snowden ?
On a tellement essayé de l'interviewer !
Et on était supposé être ceux qui auraient pu de fait avoir son interview, mais on ne l'a jamais eue.
Une autre question internet qu'on a déjà traitée...
mais je vais quand même vous la poser
par acquis de conscience :
Comment vous vérifiez l'info, comment vous sourcez ?
Plusieurs sources différentes. Il faut avoir plusieurs sources différentes.
Ne pas faire confiance à une seule source.
On a déjà plus ou moins en interne une liste noire des médias qui ont l'habitude de diffuser
de fausses informations dans certains domaines.
Et on ne les considère jamais comme source unique.
Quand le Quai d'Orsay a dit qu'il vous avait à l'œil,
ça vous a fait quoi ?
Je ressens de la pitié pour les contribuables.
Je suis vraiment désolée, mais imaginez qu'un groupe au sein du Ministère des Affaires Etrangères a été créé
uniquement pour réfléchir à une stratégie visant à nous empêcher de faire notre travail !
Ça veut dire que ces gens reçoivent leurs salaires pour, vous savez...
Vous pouvez aussi les comprendre.
Parait-il que l'équipe d'E. Macron a subi
un hacking de certains hackers russes.
Je savais que vous mettriez ce sujet sur le tapis.
N'étant pas une spécialiste dans ce domaine, je peux juste vous dire ce que j'ai appris et vérifié.
C'est une situation très délicate parce que, c'est quoi "les hackers russes" ?
Sont-ce les hackers qui utilisent une adresse IP provenant de cette partie du monde ?
ou l'alphabet cyrillique ?
Je n'ai vu aucun rapport qui prouverait que des hackers russes ont influencé, par exemple, l'élection américaine.
Là on parle carrément de tentative de pénétration et de fishing sur l'équipe d'Emmanuel Macron.
Et plus tard, En Marche a déclaré qu'il n'y avait aucune preuve de la moindre intervention russe
durant la campagne.
Donc ils l'ont dit eux-mêmes.
Si eux n'ont pas de preuves, comment les médias pourraient-ils en avoir ?
Question d'Internet : est-ce que vous avez reçu des signes d'hostilités de la part d'autres médias
ou bien peut-être des signes de sympathie ?
Il y a beaucoup de dénigrement au sujet de RT, la plupart des médias sont vraiment contre nous.
Quelques médias sont en train de devenir plus nuancés.
- Lesquels?
C'est un point délicat, parce qu'ils peuvent être nuancés aujourd'hui mais on peut trouver demain un article
totalement destructeur et biaisé.
Encore une fois, je crois que le seul média qui a évoqué RT de manière nuancée est le Monde Diplomatique,
à travers des articles qui étaient un peu meilleurs qu'ailleurs.
Comme Valeurs Actuelles ?
Valeurs Actuelles a fait un portait de moi que j'ai trouvé plutôt sympa.
Parce que d'habitude je suis dépeinte comme une James Bond girl sinistre et démoniaque
qui est venue pour conquérir la France.
On vous le reproche souvent ça ?
Être une James Bond girl russe.
Comme je l'ai dit, c'est un peu un cliché qui découle de mes origines, j'imagine.
Mais je me souviens que certains journalistes ont été bien plus honnêtes que d'autres.
Je pense au Monde. Même Le Monde a publié des articles plus ou moins gentils,
pas fondamentalement nuancés, mais un peu plus en nuances, de même que Le Figaro.
Donc parfois ça s'améliore, et parfois ça empire vraiment.
Une autre question d'internet : vous avez au cours de cette interview répondu plusieurs fois à des questions par
"Je ne suis pas autorisée à répondre".
Et la question c'est : pourquoi ? par qui ? autocensure ?
J'ai seulement dit que je ne pouvais pas donner de chiffres concernant mon salaire,
parce que c'est une clause de mon contrat.
Il y a des choses que je n'ai vraiment pas la possibilité de dire publiquement.
Et je comprends pourquoi il y a cette clause dans mon contrat, parce que ça susciterait
beaucoup de discussions entre les autres responsables de RT.
Je peux vous assurer que mon salaire n'est pas le plus élevé, ce qui ne devrait pas être une grande surprise.
Sur les autres points, je peux vous dire que je ne suis pas experte concernant ces sujets,
ni une représentante officielle de la Fédération de Russie.
Il y a le Ministère des Affaires Etrangères qui vous expliquera bien mieux que moi
où va la Russie en termes de stratégie.
Il y a beaucoup de femmes dans votre équipe ?
- Oui.
- 50/50 ?
Je n'ai pas encore compté.
Mais je peux dire que RT en général offre beaucoup de places aux femmes, à des postes de direction.
Notre rédactrice-en-chef, Margareta Simonyan, est au poste le plus élevé.
Il y a aussi la responsable de RT Español, celle de RT Arabic.
On a aussi quelques garçons : RT Royaume-Uni et RT Amérique sont dirigés par des hommes.
On passe d'ailleurs un bonjour personnel à RT Arabia.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de l'affaire Balance ton porc, en tant que femme ?
Est-ce que vous trouvez les français lourds dans la drague ?
Je n'ai pas eu assez de temps pour vraiment avoir une expérience de ce genre en France.
Je peux vous dire que c'est un moment délicat parce que d'un côté, je suis totalement pour l'égalité des droits
entre hommes et femmes.
Mais je pense aussi que l'idée de féminisme a été vraiment malmenée ces derniers temps.
On met aussi beaucoup de pression sur les hommes.
Sans rentrer dans les détails, je suis contre toute forme de violence ou de discrimination contre les femmes.
Mais je pense aussi que parfois l'idée de féminisme se perd un peu trop dans les extrêmes.
Pour vous le féminisme est trop extrême maintenant ?
Dans certains cas, oui, je pense que c'est un peu trop.
Quels cas?
Il y a plein de petites choses qui m'interrogent, comme...
Certaines campagnes sur les réseaux sociaux, pour prouver que...
Je ne veux pas entrer dans les détails, mais je pense que cela se déroule parfois
sans autre but que d'afficher sa position, son avis.
En tant que femmes, nous devrions mener des actions visibles et concrètes pour l'égalité des droits.
Par exemple en Allemagne, je me suis demandée pourquoi il y avait si peu de femmes
dans le secteur des médias. Etait-ce à cause de la pression que les hommes font peser sur les femmes ?
Et puis, j'ai appris que les femmes n'avaient pas le désir d'occuper des postes plus élevés.
Elles ne prennent pas les mesures nécessaires pour y parvenir. Ce n'est pas quelles en sont empêchées,
c'est simplement qu'elles ne le veulent pas.
Je pense que si on veut faire nos preuves, on devrait simplement essayer. Passer à la vitesse supérieure
et faire notre boulot.
Être aussi professionnelles qu'ouvertes à de nouveaux défis.
Et parfois, nous ne le sommes pas.
On devrait faire plus pour l'égalité des droits en étant exemplaire, en faisant des choses chaque jour.
Est-ce que vous avez trois qualités et trois défauts à dire par rapport aux français ?
Vous voulez dire trois qualités des français que je pourrais...
Trois qualités et trois défauts des français
C'est une question très délicate, sérieusement...
Puis-je ne parler que des bonnes choses ?
Si vous parlez des bonnes choses, il faut parler des mauvaises aussi.
D'accord, alors commençons par les points négatifs.
Comme je l'ai dit, on fait face à beaucoup d'autocensure.
Je pense que c'est une mauvaise chose pour un pays qui est historiquement connu
pour sa liberté d'expression et de parole.
En même temps, je pense qu'il y a une culture très riche.
En ce sens, je trouve vraiment que c'est une similarité avec la Russie.
Quand on parle de littérature et d'arts, et de théâtre, d'opéra, etc...
C'est quelque chose dont les français devraient être fiers, autant que de votre délicieuse et merveilleuse cuisine.
Il y a beaucoup de choses formidables en France.
Mais l'exemple le plus négativement marquant serait probablement
la fermeture d'esprit qui s'est révélée depuis peu.
3 qualités et 3 défauts pour les Russes
Seulement 3 ! ...
Nous sommes vraiment trop...
émotifs, et prêts à
prendre position et juger immédiatement.
Nous sommes très sensibles
et sincères, mais il nous faut du temps pour nous ouvrir.
Et je pense que ça prend vraiment du temps pour gagner notre confiance.
Je dirais que les Russes sont...
On adore faire la fête !
c'est parfois une bonne chose, et parfois une mauvaise.
Très récemment, nous avons eu 15 jours de congés.
J'étais tellement envieuse et jalouse,
parce que j'ai dû travailler pendant que mes amis faisaient la fête pour le nouvel an et pour Noël.
Mais sérieusement il y a
du bon et du mauvais chez chaque nationalité
et je ne soulignerai pas vraiment quoi que ce soit en particulier.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview.
On pose toujours la même question à tout le monde à chaque fois.
Ce qui n'est pas d'ailleurs une question, c'est un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Il faut que vous laissiez un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Quelque chose d'immortel sur les réseaux,
quelque chose qui dure,
à destination des jeunes générations.
Respectez toujours vos valeurs et croyez en ce que vous faites.
Ne laissez jamais personne vous empêcher d'atteindre ce que vous voulez réaliser.
Restez fidèles à vous-même.
Je pense que c'est la chose la plus importante, le plus important conseil
que je donnerais aux jeunes
qui nous écoutent et aux jeunes générations.
Xenia Federova
Merci !
Merci à vous.
Coupez !